روسيه ماكره تستنزف اسلحه الغرب دون اي
خساره
يخرج عن المالوف ويوجه رساله قويه لبوتين
بينما يكشف حقيقه انضمام اوكرانيا وبولندا
تضع يدها في الجرح الروسي والكرملين
تحملوا عواقب افعالكم الناتو يستعرض
عضلاته في المحيط وبعد استهداف اراضيها
روسيا ترد بقوه والحرب الاوكرانيه تنتقل
الى البحر فما ذنب الاسماك وسويسرا تترك
سلاحها وتعلن العوده للحياد وايران تفتح
الابواب على مصراعيها امام التفتيش النووي
حرب المحيطات تندلع في البر تدور معارك
طحن العظام وفي الجو حيث لا رحمه امام
الطائرات واما في البحر فتندلع الاشتباكات
بين حين واخر لتنصب الحرب الاوكرانيه
نفسها كاشرس حرب في القرن الحادي والعشرين
نعم يا ساده وبعد ان طالت المعارك على
البر وازدادت خسائر الطرفين حولت كييف
بوصلتها الى البحر لتعلن الدفاع الروسي ان
نظام كييف هاجم السفينه ايفان خورس
التابعه للبحريه الروسيه بسفن مسيره في
منطقه مضيق البوسفور مشيره الى ان طاقم
السفينه صد الهجوم بنجاح ليتمكنوا من
تدمير جميع الزوارق المسيره بنيران اسلحه
عاديه وذلك وفق بيان الوزاره الروسيه هذا
ما تقوم به السفينه ايفان خروس بمهام
لضمان سلامه تشغيل خط انابيب الغاز السيل
التركي والسيل الازرق في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه خالصه لجمهوريه تركيا وفي
البحر تستمر المعارك لترتفع حده التوترات
بين الغرب وروسيا حيث ابحرت حامله
الطائرات جيرالد وهي اكبر حامله طائرات في
العالم الى اوسلو في اول مشاركه لسفينه
امريكيه من هذا النوع فيما اعتبر استعراضا
لقوه النيتو وذلك في ظل تصاعد ازمه التوتر
بين الحلف وروسيا بسبب حرب اوكرانيا ليقول
الجيش النرويجي ان السفينه وطاقمها سيجرون
تدريبات مع القوات المسلحه النرويجيه على
طول ساحل البلاد في الايام المقبله الرد
الروسي جاء سريعا حين نددت السفاره
الروسيه في اسلوب زياره حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه واضافت انه لا توجد مشكله في
القطب الشمالي تتطلب حلا عسكريا ولا قضايا
تحتاج تدخلا خارجيا اي انهم يتساءلون ما
الذي جاء بحامله الطائره الامريكيه الى
هنا فبماذا ستجيب واشنطن وبينما تتواصل
الحرب الاوكرانيه يزداد سعيرها هنا صرح
مصدر عسكري مطلع ان منظومه الدفاع الجوي
الصاروخيه الروسيه
350 فتياز اسقطت اطول مره طائره حربيه
اوكرانيه بشكل اوتوماتيكي دون مشاركه
بشريه حيث تم اكتشاف هدف جوي اوكراني
ومتابعته واسقاطه دون اوامر من البشر وذلك
بحسب وكاله نوفوستي وهنا يلجا الروس الى
خطه ماكره تستنزف الاسلحه الاوكرانيه
والغربيه في اوكرانيا حيث يستخدم الجيش
الروسي في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
مسيره جويه ذات تصميم مميز لخداع الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه وذلك لانها مصنوعه من
الخشب والبلاستيك الرغوي ويتم تجميعها
بواسطه شريط لاصق ليطلق الاوكران ذخيرتهم
التي تعادل الالاف او بيئات الالاف من
الدولارات مقابل قطعه خشبيه بلاستيكيه في
هذا المكر الروسي الخبيث ومع التقدم
الروسي والخسائر الاوكرانيه لازال طباخ
بوتين
يسبح عكس الطيار حيث قال رئيس مجموعه
فاغنار ان اكثر من عشرين الفا من قوته
لقوا حتفهم في المعركه الطويله للسيطره
على باخما وذلك خلافا لما اعلنت عنه
الدفاع الروسي التي قالت انها خسرت قرابه
السته الاف جنديا في باخما فهل يقول
بريجوجان الحقيقه ام ان له مارب اخرى
لتاخذنا الاحداث قليلا نحو الاراضي
الروسيه وبعد ان تم استهداف مقاطعه بيلجا
الروسيه بالمسيرات اضافه لمحاوله مجموعه
من الجنود اختراق العنق الروسي قال وزير
الدفاع الروسي ان موسكو سترد بطريقه قاسيه
جدا على اقتحام الاوكران لبلغوراد وهنا
عادت كييف لتنفي ذلك وعلى لسان نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
التي اكدت ان بلادها
ان مساله انضمام اوكرانيا الى الحلف قبل
انتهاء النزاح المسلح مع روسيا ليست
مطروحه على الطاوله والى خارج اوكرانيا
تتوسع الحرب الروسيه وبولندا قد تكون
الحصان الخاسره هذه المره اذا طالت اميران
بوتات حيث كان نائب وزير الدفاع الوطني
البولندي السابق الجنرال فلادي قد قال في
تصريحات سابقه ان بولندا تستعد لانقلاب
المسلح في بيلاروسيا والمشاركه في الدعم
العسكري وفق ما اوردته وكاله نوفوست
الروسيه ليرد متحدث الكريمل
هولندا دوله معاديه لنا اود ان اذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك لانه لسوء الحظ فان القياده
البولنديه تدخل الان فعليا في هستيريا
روها بروسيا مضيفا ان بولندا تريد التدخل
في دوله المجاوره واردف بيسكو ان هذه
الدوله المجاوره في اشاره لبيلاروسيا هي
الشريك والحليف الدوله الشقيقه لنا
وبطبيعه الحال فلوسيا ملتزمه بضمان امن من
بيلاروسيا الى سويسرا دوله الحياد في
العالم التي كانت قد خرجت عن حيادها قليلا
لتعلن اليوم الحكومه السويسريه رغبتها في
بيع 25 دبابه ليوبارد غير مستخدمه لديها
الى الشركه الالمانيه المصنعه لوضعها في
متناول الجيش الالماني او الشركاء في حلف
الناتو وذلك بعد تعهد برلين بعدم نقل
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا بناء على طلب
سويسرا برايكم ما الذي جعل سويسرا تعود
الى حيادها مره اخرى
الاحداث والتطورات
اكد البيت الابيض انه لا ينوي في الوقت
الراهن اللجوء الى الماده الرابعه عشر من
الدستور الامريكي لرفع سقف الدين ومنع
تخلف الولايات المتحده عن السداد المنافس
الرئيسي لتراف على ورقه الحزب الجمهوري
ديدس سانتيس يعلن ترشحه رسميا لسباق البيت
الابيض اكدت ايران استعدادها للتعاون
التام مع المفتشين الدوليين وذلك عقب
الكشف عن انشاءات جديده قرب منشات نوويه
وكانت اسرائيل لوحت بتحرك عسكري ضد ايران
مع استمرار رفعها لنسب تخصيب اليورانيوم
بولندا تشد الانظار الروسيه نحوها فهل
تتحول ضربات الروس ايضا نحو الاراضي
البولنديه
[موسيقى]